est-ce qu'il pense que c'est de nous que
dépend de veiller à ce qu'il y ait un
toit pour tous les Français non enfin
sans blague et pourquoi il l'a pas fait
si c'est un citoyen individuel de le
faire mais ta gueule fa
fais-le bonjour c'est une heure de
vérité exceptionnelle que nous vous
présentons aujourd'hui d'abord à cause
de la personnalité de notre invité
l'abbé Pierre et ensuite parce que nous
avons quitté notre studio de Paris où
vous êtes venu d'ailleurs à plusieurs
reprises monsieur laabé soutenir des
hommes politiques et nous avons installé
nos caméras ici aujourd'hui à
estville une des 105 maisons que votre
association possède en France nous
sommes à une vingtaine de kilomètres au
au nord de rouan et c'est dans cette
maison de retraite que vous avez décidé
de finir vos jours au milieu des
compagnons des Maus dont vous êtes
aujourd'hui le doyen du haut de vos 81
ans alors il y a ici autour de vous les
compagn
de cette maison de d''esteville mais
aussi ceux des autres communautés
normandes et ceux qui sont venus de la
communauté de montbellliard dirigé ici
par Micheline qui est là dans la salle
et puis deux invités venus de Paris le
docteur couchner avec lequel vous venez
d'écrire ce livre Dieu et et les hommes
publié chez Lafond et le grand
mathématicien biologiste généticien et
démographe Albert jacard avec lequel
vous préparez à publier un autre livre
sous le titre d'absolu voilà alors pour
les jeunes qui connaissent pas votre
fabuleuse aventure je rappelle que vous
êtes né à Lyon en en août 1912 dans une
famille bourgeoise d'industriel de la
soirie le jour de la fête de Notre-Dame
des Neiges euh votre vrai nom est Henri
grues et dès l'âge de 19 ans vous avez
été moine capucin moin cloîré et vous
portez d'ailleurs toujours pendant 7 ans
pendant 7 ans vous l'avez été et vous
portez d'ailleurs toujours la la bure
des capucinss vous avez fait la guerre
de 1939 euh puis vous avez pris le Maqui
d'abord en Grande Chartreuse puis
ensuite dans le vercor la libération on
vous retrouve député de murtemosel
euh vous conduisez une liste MRP
c'est-à-dire chrétiendémocrate centriste
hein comme on dirait aujourd'hui mais
vous-même vous avez tenu à garder tout
au moins pendant un certain temps votre
étiquette d'indépendant en 1949 c'est la
création de l'association des
chiffonniers des Maus à Neï plaisance à
l'est de Paris et puis 5 ans plus tard
ce c'est les fameux appels de février 54
qui vous ont rendu célèbres euh article
dans Le Figaro puis appel sur les
antenne de RTL l'hiver avait été
terrible un un nourrisson était mort de
froid dans un un bidonville au moment
même où le Parlement venait de repousser
votre demande d'un budget exceptionnel
d'un milliard de francs euh pour de Fran
de l'époque pour la construction de cité
d'urgence un milliard de francs c'est
très exactement ce que la guerre
d'Algérie qui allait se déclenché
quelques mois plus tard coûtait par jour
par jour euh dans le Figaro vous avez
supplié le ministre du Logement de
l'époque de venir assister à
l'enterrement du nourrisson vous vous en
souvenez il s'appelait Monsieur le Maire
et il s'est pas dégonflé il est venu
hein euh les choses n'ont guère changé
depuis 1954 malgré vos efforts il y a
aujourd'hui autant de sans abri qu'il y
a d'employés de la SNCF et des postes
réunis en France et hier samedi dans
leurloire on a enterré un bébé qui est
mort de froid parce que EDF avait coupé
le courant à sa famille qui ne pouvait
plus payer ses
factures de temps en temps l'indignation
est trop forte pour vous alors vous
quittez cette maison d''esteville et
vous allez comme autrefois prendre la
défense des sansabris on va voir tout de
suite ce qui s passé le 24 septembre à
Paris lorsque vous êtes allé au secours
des squatters expulsés de l'avenue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ren je ne quitterai pas ce trottoir la
répse tant que ne sera pas respecté la
décision de la Cour d'appel et tant que
n'aura pas été ouvert une porte pour que
cette famillees entent là où la cour
d'appel leur a donné le droit d'abriter
leur famille et leurs petits- enfants je
ne sortirai pas de ce coin de trottoir
jusqu'à ce que cela soit fait voilà
c'est exactement comme quand vous aviez
35 ans alors on va découper cette
émission en trois parties he nous
parlerons du problème des sansabris et
de tous ceux qui sont exclus de notre
société avec alin duamel puis Henry t du
journal Le Monde vous interrogera le
prêtre que vous êtes et qu'on connaît
moins bien que l'homme d'action enfin
Jean-Marie Colombani vous fera parler de
vos rapports avec le monde politique et
des grands problèmes de la société
française on commence tout de suite avec
Alain
duamel bonjour monsieur l'ABB comment
est-ce que vous expliquez ça sera
l'année prochaine ça fera 40 ans que
vous menez cette action spécifique
comment est-ce que vous expliquez que 40
ans après il faut encore que ce soit
vous et il faut encore que chaque année
pratiquement vous soyez obligé d'aller
protester et crier votre
indignation d'abord soyons bien dans la
vérité il n'y a pas que moi il se fait
que par une série de circonstances et
contrairement à ce que certains
pensent l'action on don j'ai été la
vedette à aucun moment n'a été quelque
chose de prévu ça a été toujours des
circonstances passant et bon on peut se
dérober et le réflexe était de qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire et
oui ça été de
l'imprévu et beaucoup d'autres font les
mêmes choses que je fais et puis ça fait
moins vedette parce que il y a eu le
fait d'un prêtre devenu député décoré de
la guerre apparenté un de mes frères
apparenté à de Gaulle et cetera et ça
faisait
Vette c'est pas drôle d'ailleurs d' dans
cette position just justement vous êtes
le le dernier sondage de l'iphob dans le
Journal du Dimanche l'avait montré vous
êtes aujourd'hui l'homme le plus
populaire de France dans votre action
est-ce que c'est au fond une grâce votre
popularité est-ce que c'est une arme ou
est-ce que c'est une croix c'est à la
fois une arme et c'est une croix c'est
vrai quand j'ai étais très fréquemment
malade et au moment où Brigit bardau
j'étais à la clinique a fait une
tentative de suicide je n'ai pas pu me
retenir de dire l'infirmière comme je la
comprends son impressario a besoin pour
faire son métier de la mettre en Vette
de la mettre partout et il arrive un
moment ou s'il n'y a pas une vie
spirituelle profonde sur laquelle
s'appuyer et qui fait prendre toucher
une autre dimension c'est insupportable
mais mais vous le fait que vous soyez ce
que vous êtes que vous ayez la notoriété
que vous avez ça fait que quand vous
parlez on est obligé de vous écouter et
que quand vous vous déplacez on est
obligé de vous répondre oui c'est en ça
que c'est une arme et j'aurais tort de
ne pas l'utiliser il faut mesurer la
responsabilité ça oblige quelquefois à
dire des choses déplaisantes même
inévitablement vous parliez il y a un
instant de ce qui est arrivé à vnucoti
il faut en connaître la réalité que la
presse ne peut pas complètement
expliquer mais c'est c'est un événement
énorme qui venait de se produire
n'est-ce pas il y avait là un immeuble
vaste qui pouvait héberger peut-être 30
ou 40 familles en parfait état depuis 3
ans vide et loué à une association la
ville de Paris n'avait pas renouvelé la
location mais le président de
l'association continue à y habiter et il
a donner ce président de l'association à
chacune des familles qui allaient entrer
un papier disant qu'il les autorisa en
tant que lui-même seul occupant des
lieux
or
le le jour même
où la cour d'appel à laquelle c'était
adressé ses
familles accompli un acte tout à fait
nouveau unique dans l'histoire
judiciaire française la cour
d'appel reconnaît que les familles ayant
violé la
loi par
nécessité on devait leur donner des
délais qui s'étendait à 6 mois
or je reçois la veille au soir plutôt je
reçois la veille de ma venue à Paris je
reçois des téléphones de papa de maman
qui me disent devant l'avenue côti il y
a un large terreplein les fenêtres du
rchaussé étaient muré mais à distance il
il voyait ce qui se passait au premier
étage et il voyait que des machines
énormes étaient entré par derrière
étaiit en train de broyer la totalité de
l'intérieur de l'immeuble et il ils
étaient en larme alors qu'il ne savaient
pas où ils iraient avec leurs enfants on
les avait mis à l'abri dans des des
coins comme on pouvait alors à 2h du
matin professeur jacard votre épouse a
été souriante elle reconnu ma voix et
elle m'a dit c'est mon mari je vous
rechercher il est là elle vous a
réveillé et je vous ai dit je peux plus
supporter ça demain je vais j'ai dit que
ne porterai plus mes décorations je ne
les porte plus mais je vais aller chez
Artus Bertrand lui demander s'il aurait
pas encore une une cravate de Commandeur
et de me la passer pour que je mette
tout ce que je peux comme poids et j'ai
été dire au capitaine qui commander la
troupe qui était là mon capitaine je ne
quitterai pas ces lieux tant que
j'aurais pas la clé pour rentrer il a
fallu 4 à 5 heur de palabre et
finalement le l'adjoint au logement de
la ville de Paris m'a dit avec Monsieur
jacard avec l'avocat Jean-Jacques de
Félice vous voulez entrer je vais vous
en faire entrer et on a ouvert la porte
et croyez-moi si je n'avais pas toute ma
vie été un homme qui a voulu lutter
contre la violence j'aurais frappé la
juin je leuri jeté sur l'accumulation de
gravat que ce que peut représenter la
démolition de deux étages d'un immeuble
alors que les les familles sont là à ne
pas savoir où elles iront l'hiver mais
alors évidemment les squatter c'est une
solution qui est forcément une solution
de désespoir alors vous qu'est-ce que
vous préconisez est-ce que vous au fond
est-ce que vous connaissez dans une
société une solution possible un peu e
qui permettent d'éviter d'en arriver à
ces situations là il y a il y a
plusieurs solutions une elle est très
importante la loi Besson qui a
été publiée et approuvée il y a 2 ans
cette loi prévoit entre autres ce qu'on
appelle le bail réhabilitation des
associations peuvent devenir locataires
de locaux inhabités et pour lesquels il
y a des travaux à faire des crédits nont
prévu pour que les travaux se fassent
pour qu' l'au les cabinets et cetera et
ça marche et et c'est ça marchera si
nous le faisons savoir et votre émission
est utile pour cela et nous il faut que
je demande au cardinal de dire qu'il
faut que dans des prêches on dit à des
fidèles où il y a des des quantités de
très braves gens mais souvent des
personnes âgées et qui peuvent pas se
faire des cass-etêtes mais les rassuré
en leur disant tout est prévu pour que
vous ayez une ass
iation tuteur des locataires qui seront
là n'est-ce pas vous serez certain et au
bout de 12 années c'est l'association
qui empochera le loyer au bout de 12
années ça fait partie de votre
patrimoine vous récupérez le comment dit
on peut les aider sans laisser les
propriétaires et même en améliorant le
bien que le propriétaire lesera après
lui bon il y a il y a d'autres moyens il
existe des locaux en quantité énorme
dans Paris parfaitement connu il y en a
qui sont des locaux pour ambassadeurs ou
pour grandes sociétés qui sont pas pour
des gens modeste mais il y en a
plusieurs milliers connus comme étant
350000 généralement on estime pour la
France 350 350000 pour la France pour
l'ensemble de la France n'est-ce pas
mais dans Paris mais dans Paris
peut-être une centaine de mil000
n'est-ce pas c'est pas impossible ça
vous paraît un problème surtout parisien
et Île-de France ou bien un problème
national
le problème il a il repose sur deux
chiffres qui ont été établis dans le
rapport au Conseil économique établi par
le Père Joseph ranski on n'a pas
contesté ces chiffres depuis lors il y
aurait en France actuellement 2 millions
et demi de familles qu'on appelle mal
logé la définition de mal logé c'est
trois points ou bien plusieurs couples
dans un logement sans eau sans cabinet
bon il y aurait 2500 2 millions et demi
c'est-à-dire qu'il suffirait d'avoir
bâti un million de logements pour avoir
fait éclater déjà ce fait ce
dédoublement on sait les désastres
qu'entraînent la cohabitation trop
longue de plusieurs couples est-ce que
vous d'après ce que vous voyez la
situation est plutôt pire maintenant que
au moment où vous avez commencé en 1954
la même chose différentes très
différentes euh il faut savoir d'abord
une information que je n que depuis très
peu de temps de sources très sûr et qui
est très encourageante autant pour des
hommes politiques de tous les bords qui
ont traversé ces longues années que pour
les militants qui ont lutté
euh quand la guerre finissait dans cette
situation de mal loger comme nous la
définition il y a un instant ont ComptAÉ
29 % des familles françaises ce qui
n'était pas étonnant après la guerre
tout le long
des log av disparu des couples venai
séberg chez les parents chez les frères
et sœs bon c'était pas étonnant or
actuellement il n'y a plus que 9 % des
familles françaises qui se trouvent dans
cet état de mal loger donc on a quand
même pas perdu son temps on n'a pas rien
fait mais il faut aussi être très
réaliste 9 % des famille française dans
cette situation ça représente grosso
modo 5 millions de personnes hommes FEM
vieillard enfant et cetera estce est-ce
que vous vous sentez puisque vous avez
une expérience longue est-ce que vous
sentez les gens aujourd'hui aussi
solidaire qu'il y a 40 ans moins
solidaire ou solidaire de façon
différente c'est pas la question
fondamentale n'est pas de solidarité la
question fondamentale elle est comme
différence dans le fait que il y a 40
ans on sortait de la guerre et on
regorgeit de projets d'espérance vous
vouz dire d'espérance on avait des des
projets à tel point d'ailleurs que la
France allait chercher des travailleurs
étrangers portugais ou maghrébains les
Algériens qui n'avaient pas besoin de
carte de séjour ni de travail citoyens
français j'étais député à cette époque
j'ai connu les combats que menait
monsieur fondlup spéraabert député qui
était le spécialiste des problèmes de
l'Algérie des patrons pas tous les
patrons le patronnat mais des patrons
sans scrupule fretter des cargots avec
des racoleurs qui allaient dans les
villages de l'Algérie pour avoir du
surnombre de main- d'œuvre pour contrer
les revendications syndicales et pour
plus vite nous aider à débarrasser nos
ruines quand maintenant on entend une
certaine catégorie de personnes voz à
qui je pense euh bien qui trouve qu'il y
en a de trop de ceux-là ben il faut
rappeler premièrement que c'est pas eux
qui sont venus occuper la France avec
des armes nous avons été occuper leur
pays deuxièmement quand en 14 il a fallu
sauver notre liberté nous les avons
mobilisé et ils sont mort par dizaines
de milles je viens d'avoir hier une
information qui a une valeur nationale
qui parmi vous c'est qu'il existe une
délégation à la mémoire et à
l'information historique au ministère
des Anciens combattants qui d'entre nous
le sait une délégation à la mê MMO
quelle merveilleuse appellation je
voudrais que j'ai demandé des chiffres
dans les nécropoles de la guerre de 14
il y a 21000 musulmans sans compter les
ossuires où on ne peut distinguer
personne de la campagne 39 45 au
débarquement de 45 de Méditerranée plus
de 10000 morts et pendant la guerre du
Vietnam c'était pas des magrébins mais
5000 vietnamiens mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous pensez que
il faut comme le disent la plupart des
responsables ce qu'on appelle stabiliser
l'immigration ça veut dire pratiquement
la limité c'est évident qu'on pourra pas
recevoir tout le monde mais c'est
évident aussi qu historiquement on a
jamais vu que sur un espace aussi petit
que le bassin méditerranéen il y ait au
nord une Europe ultra fertile les terres
les plus fertiles du monde de moins en
moins
peuplé face à de l'autre côté de la mer
des peuples qui étaient en nombre Maroc
Algérie Tunisie le la moitié du nombre
des Français et dans 20 ou 30 ans ils
seront le triple donc faut les aider à
se développer il faut les aider à se
développer il faut les aider à rendre
leur terre plus fertile et et il faut
prévoir que c'est inévitable nous en
verrons venir lorsque nous voyons la
télévision il y a quelques jours un
médecin qui sait qu'il est menacé de
mort qui est algérien un de mes vient
d'être tué il y a 2 mois médecin
pédiatre avec lequel nous préparions une
fondation à Alger et lorsqu'on voit ce
médecin on le voyait que de dos mais
qu'on voyait marcher dans les rues tout
seul et qu'on nous disait on lui chicane
le droit d'asile parce qu'il ne peut pas
prouver qu'il est en danger de mort
est-ce qu'il faut attendre qu'il a été
tué merci et et nous aurons bonne nuin
si les intégristes c'est l'emporté en
Algérie et si nous voyons par dizaines
de milles les plus proches de nous de
notre culture et cetera venir nous
demander sauvez-nous on aura bonne mine
de leur faire des grimaces donc Cuxa il
faut les accueillir il faudra bien merci
à la duavel alors là on vient de voir
l'homme
d'action on voudrait maintenant en
savoir plus sur le prêtre que vous êtes
avec Henry Ting bonjour père bonjour je
voudrais vous connaître un peu plus donc
comme homme d'église dans ce combat pour
protéger l'immigré dans ce combat pour
protéger les mal logés est-ce que vous
vous sentez suffisamment soutenu par
votre église ou bien est-ce que vous
trouvez que l'Église est encore un peu
trop disons peureuse frileuse par
rapport aux injustices par rapport aux
exclusions l'Église ne sera jamais
suffisamment engagée prête à se mouiller
avec chacun de ces du haut en bas de
depuis les prélas les plus haut jusque
au plus humble petit enfant qui a la foi
l'église est appelée à
une une vocation si merveilleuse que
elle sera toujours débile inférieure
n'est-ce pas
euh je j'aime définir d'abord qu'est-ce
que c'est que le prêtre n'est-ce pas je
n'aime pas la distinction dont on abuse
clair et laïque on a tellement ça nous
évoque les privilèges d'éclair dans
d'autres siècles aujourd'hui ils n'en
ont pas beaucoup mais de l'histoire
passée n'est-ce pas je
j'aime dire le prêtre sa
mission c'est de réaliser l'Eucharistie
du monde le mot Eucharistie veut dire
dire merci c'est une belle formule faire
faire que le monde dise merci et pour
cela vous devinez vous mesurez tout ce
que cela suppose que l'on réalise étape
par étape et j'ai dit au Saint-Père je
le répète sans cesse à toute occasion
l'expression traditionnelle évangélique
de Pasteur
pour l'homme contemporain qui n'a pas
connu la vie pastorale ou du moins il y
a très longtemps c'est pas tellement
grisant de s'entendre appeler mouton et
et et si on va un peu loin le berger
estant un bon pasteur pour mener une
bonne bête à la boucherie n'est-ce pas
le prêtre j'aime mieux le voir premier
de cord je disais ça au pape il aime la
montagne ça lu va pas d'plu et et je me
sens plus premier de corderé rest able
de cette manière que alors on sait que
les premiers de cordé les prêtres
aujourd'hui vivent pauvrement dans dans
la société il gagne pas plus que le SMIC
mais pour pour vous le le le travail du
prêtre aujourd'hui quel est-il quel
est-il exactement il est de rendre
croyable est-ce que est-ce que cette
église qu'il est censé servir est-ce
qu'elle est pas encore prisonnier d'une
certaine image de de de richesse de
pouvoir et qui handicape votre action
auprès des plus
pauvres ce qui est particulièrement
narant c'est que l'Église continue à
faire comme si elle était riche alors
que depuis le passage de l'illustre prê
américain dont on ne sait pas très bien
ce qu'il a fait de tout ce qu'il y avait
de réserve financière euh entre les
mains du Saint-Père euh l'église n'est
pas riche ce n'est pas vrai Monseigneur
marcincus non oui bien sûr je nai pas la
mémoire des noms mais il est inoubliable
n'est-ce pas l'église se trouve à pauvri
ce n'est plus vrai qu'elle est riche je
peux pas supporter qu'elle joue la
comédie qu'elle supporte que quand le
pape se déplacer bon c'est pas
supportable qu'il y ait des dépenses
faites pour lui plus grandes que celles
qu'on fait pour les hommes les plus
puissants de l'univers qui a un tapis
rouge qu' qu'on aille dans le salon
d'accueil qu'on se dise quelques mots
euh entre autorité bravo mais je me
rappellerai toute ma vie cette jeune
femme belge qui avait été jossice et qui
avait été prié de
présenter une parole au pape et quand
elle a vu les frais que la Ville de
Bruxelles faisait de la poche des
contribuables croyant ou pas et et d'une
manière tellement fastueuse etcoutteuse
elle a commencé par refuser puis elle a
repris sa décision et elle est venu le
dire au pape ouais
venu lui dire ce n'est pas tolérable
vous nous tirer dans le dos nous nous
voulons faire croire que que l'Éternel
est Amour que l'amour c'est le partage
que les plus forts sont ce servic des
plus faibles et et et vous vous vous
acceptez que on on vous idolâtre alors
que Jésus euh n'est pas venu en Cadillac
il est monté sur un âne et et et quand
on a voulu le faire roi il a fit camp
vous avez dit une fois que le pape
devrait démissionner à l'âge de 75 ans
et se retirer dans un Monast c'est pas
tout à fait ça c'est pas tout à fait ça
la réalité je me trouvais avec une
petite troupe de théâtre qui présentait
une ve saint-rançois d'assis le petit PA
et un ami qui était le prél délégué à
l'Unesco ayant vu la pièce a dit il faut
montrer ça au pape pendant l'été à
Castel gandolp et ce brave prélade de
l'UNESCO a organisé alors nous étions la
très peu nombreux il y avait 20 ou 30
personnes de l'extérieur il y avait les
acteurs et puis le PAP est descendu on
avait mis un fauteuil et et de chaises à
sa gauche il avait un secrétaire
vietnamien et puis j'était à sa droite
alors au bout d'un moment le pape me dit
et quel âge avez-vous alors je lui dis
alors il dit mais le P est plus jeune
que vous et c'est alors que je lui ai
dit mais qui sait peut-être bien que le
pape quand il aura 75 ans comme évêque
de Rome il fera ce qu'il impose à tout
évêque à travers le monde qui est à 75
ans non pas de démissionner mais de
proposer sa démission pour éviter
d'avoir un vieux gâteux qui paralyse la
diocèse la la vieillesse de de Pidou a
été un désastre pour pour l'Église
n'est-ce pas parce que il n'en finissait
pas de mourir et comme bien des vieux il
disait laissez-moi ça je m'en
occupe à tel point que monant Montini
devenu le Paul VI a démissionné de sa
charge de substituer la secrétaire d'ID
les deux ils étaient de Tardini et
Montini ils ont
démissionné aun seul pape dans
l'histoire
il y en a qu'un et et c'est TR rigolo de
rappeler comment alors attendez ce qui
est important c'est de savoir qu'est-ce
que le PAP répond alors le PAP sourit et
puis il me
dit ça demande
réflexion
bien depu et depuis ce temps j'entends
par-ci par là où je lis dans les
journaux le Vatican fait savoir que le
pape n'a pas l'intention de
démissionner alors ce papeè prend des
positions pour les droits de l'homme
contre la la pauvreté mais aussi prendre
des positions dans le domaine moral qui
qui dérange un grand nombre de personnes
alors je voudrais savoir comment vous
situez par rapport à ces interdits que
pose l'église et et je pense notamment à
l'affaire du sida vous avez dit un jour
à défaut d'être des saints ne soyez pas
des assassins alors ça veut dire que
vous êtes pour l'usage du du préservatif
vous savez que demain on va vendre le
préservatif peut-être à un franc est-ce
que vous en retenez la parole tiers ce
que j'ai dit et ça a été repris par le
cardinal de Paris ça passé dans
l'observatoire Romano ce que j'ai dit
c'est l'Évangile nous appelle à une
perfection totale et qui peut demander
un véritable héroïsme dans certaines
circonstances nous sommes des pauvres
êtres humains et nous nous commettons
des fautes si dans ce domaine il vous
arrive un adultère vous comm étez la
faute n'ajoutez pas le crime à la faute
car la seule le seul préservatif total
absolu certain pour deux personnes qui
sont fait examiner et qui sont certains
que leur sang est
indème c'est la fidélité s'il y a la
fidélité ils peuvent dormir tranquille
n'est-ce pas c'est la fidélité bien
entendu qui
suppose veut qu'on fasse tout pour que
l'amour accompagne la fidélité la
fidélité d'ailleurs s'il n'y avait pas
l'amour est-ce que la fidélité
subsisterait les deux sont étroitement
unis donc ne séparons pas les choses je
je n'ai pas dit fautez mais mais mais
mais prenez un préservatif j'ai dit si
vous fautez alors n'ayez pas la lâcheté
de ne pas prendre de préservatif
monsieur Lab vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure du du prêtre le problème c'est
que il y en a de de moins en moins il y
a une crise de voocation qui est très
très grave alors qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour relancer la vocation
est-ce que par exemple mettre fin au au
à la règle du du célibat des prêtres
est-ce que ce serait une solution il
faut regarder les choses dans leur
pleine réalité euh le célibat n'est que
dans une partie la plus importante des
différentes familles de l'Église
catholique nous avons des frères
maronites en très grand nombre ils ont
mariés au Liban des Coptes des Grecs
n'est-ce pas et bon deuxièmement
historiquement le le le la liaison du
célibat avec euh les engagements
monastiques de de je veux dire du
sacerdo avec les engagements monastiques
de célibat bon elle ne s'est faite que
très très mal elle n'a jamais été totale
je connais des évêques d'Amérique latine
qui répète euh je le sais il n'y a pas
euh il y a qu'un très petit pourcentage
des prêtes perdus dans la solitude dans
la montagne pour lesquels il faut un
temps fou pour rencontrer un autre
prêtre n'est-ce pas mais je sais que et
et dans un monde où pour la famille qui
arriverait à mettre dans le lit du curé
une fille de la famille c'est l'honneur
le plus grand qui pourrait lui arriver
n'est-ce pas donc est-ce qu'il faut pas
mettre fin à l'hypocrisie mon père oui
le le mensonge est pire que tout
n'est-ce pas et et mais alors regardons
les choses comme elles ont été euh à
l'origine euh c'était les communautés de
fidèles qui euh présentaient à l'évêque
ce qu'il souhaitait voir appeler et
l'évêque appelé vauaré bon
et progressivement au f et unure de la
décadence de l'empire de Rome euh de
plus en plus nombreux étaient les moines
comme dans notre société en décadence
actuellement eu allant chercher la
solitude et le désert perdant
l'espérance dans les choses de ce monde
bon et progressivement les communautés
de fidèles ont présenté de plus en plus
seulement des moine à l'évêque demandant
qu'on les ordonne parce que il savait
que ce moine pourrait se consacrer
davantage à son apostolat et ce n'est
que très très lentement que c'est devenu
un canon comme on dit UNE une c'est vrai
il y a eu des détours historique bon
mais mais au fond qu'est-ce qui
empêcherait aujourd'hui pour vous
l'ordination du d'une femme quand même
alors c'est un autre problème qu'il faut
leseréparer c'est quand même la crise
d'é voocation oui mais vous posez deux
problèmes le problème d'une part de
prêtre ordonn prêtre des hommes mariés
et d'autre part vous posez le problème
de femmes pouvant comme l'église
d'anglicane vient de l'admettre être
ordonné alors j'ai bien cherché je suis
pas un savant théologien n'est-ce pas
j'ai bien cherché mais théologiquement
bibliquement je ne vois vraiment aucun
aucun argument théologique contraignant
on peut trouver à l'ordination féminine
des convenances selon les sociétés les
usages les et cetera mais un argument
théologique j'ai entendu ceux qui sont
pour ceux qui sont contre je n'ai trouvé
ni d'un côté ni de l'autre un argument
déterminant monsieur Pasco a dit l'autre
jour que le travail des prêtres était
d'aller évangéliser les bon plutôt que
de lutter contre ces projets en matière
d'immigration est-ce qu'il a est-ce
qu'il a raison ou pas je lui dirais
simplement que si les croyances que je
ne sais pas et je l'espère je le lui
souhaite mais s'il est croyant il il lui
appartient à lui autant qu'à moi prêtre
de se conduire d'une manière qui rende
croyable
l'Évangile et que ça ne soit pas et
c'est pas ce qu' fait et c'est pas ce
qui fait je c'était aussi une manière de
dire que le clerger ferait mieux de
s'occuper comme on disait dans le temps
de ces oignons et ne lutteit pas contre
ses projets sur l'immigration bien sûr
phase l'amiral de Jobert j'aimerais
j'aimerais le mettre en présence des cas
encher et en os précis dramatique de tel
CDE qui pleurer en me disant on a tué
mon frère devant moi ma mère m'a dit fui
j'ai réussi à partir mais je peux pas
prouver qu'on a tué mon frère je peux
j'ai pas des marques de torture et et on
veut fourrer dans un avion alors je sais
que qu'on m'en voie sur la partie kurde
de la Turquie ou de
la je plus le nom du l'Irak n'est-ce pas
je sais que à l'arrivée je suis tué et
que déjà ma maison ma ferme s'est donné
à d'autres n'est-ce pas le kurde on sait
bien que s'il a quitté le pays ça pas
été pour dire du bien du gouvernement
donc il est perdu et et je me rappelle
un autre qui alors lui pouvait faire les
preuves il dé tier sa chemise pour me
montrer les traces des brûlures des
blessures qu'il avait eu dans les
supplices qu'il avait subi n'est-ce pas
alors euh devant des cas bien précis euh
j'ai eu j'ai eu
à à passer une année à suivre avec le
président des églises protestantes de
France
etur Start et puis euh un préfet le
préfet Monestier et puis l'ancien
président de la C CFDT a suiv pendant
unant l'application de la circulaire
Bianco pour réglementer de nouvelle
manière
les le droit d'asile or il y a eu
finalement on disait de ne pas le dire
trop tôt parce que Monsieur Le Pen
allait nous traiter de vendre la France
aux étrangers mais sur 80 dossiers qui
étaient à la traain avec des types qui
avaient un permis provisoire depuis 10
ans et nous avions très peur en voyant
la circulaire telle que finalement elle
a été promulgué mais il y a eu quand
même 27000 sur les 80000 qui ont reçu le
droit d'asile c'était bien mieux que ce
que nous espérions mais à la Réunion
finale j'ai demandé aux trois ministres
qui étaient là encore sais pass quoi
ministre d'intérieur Premier ministre et
ca je leur ai dit ce que nous disions
tout à l'heure si demain l'Algérie était
intégriste et que vous PZ venir deux ou
trois dizaines de m000 venant pleurer à
notre porte qu'est-ce que vous feriez il
y avait pas pensé merci Henri t alors
jemie Colombani avec Jean-Marie
Colombani on va peut-être revenir sur
Monsieur Le Pen vous avez cité le nom
puce qu'il a fait des déclarations hier
soir à
Bordeaux assez dur contre vous mais
auparavant je voudrais qu'on regarde une
scène qui s'est passée il y a 15 jours à
l'inauguration de la première boutique
de la solidarité rubicha à Paris vous y
étiez et vous n'étiez pas seul un Baer à
Simone veille c'est ainsi que l'abbé
Pierre accueillait ce matin le ministre
des Affaires sociales venu lancer avec
lui la première boutique solidarité de
la capitale elle ouvrira dans 2
mois Jean-Marie Colombani ben justement
d'un mot puisque puisque François Henri
y a fait allusion Jean-Marie Le Pen dans
une déclaration hier vous a accusé
d'abord d'éructter je cite Jean-Marie Le
Pen et ensuite de ne pas avoir vous-même
prévu les rudesses de l'hiver et de ne
pas avoir vous-même en tant
qu'association charitable fait le
nécessaire est que est-ce que vous avez
lui répondre dire tout à l'heure le Le
Pen a dit que vous é ruptier je me suis
dit j'aurais pas trouvé ce mot tout seul
il a d rester trop longtemps à se
regarder dans la glace ou à écouter ses
propres ses propres
discours
car
c'est ça m'est plutôt agréable de ne pas
me trouver que personne ne suppose que
je puisse éprouver la moindre sympathie
pour l'ami de Monsieur gr le chef des
nazis belges réfugié avec une fortune en
Espagne où euh hier il a déclaré sa joie
si dimanche les néofascistes l'emportent
en Italie il avait pas besoin de le dire
on s'en doutait n'est-ce pas
euh
mais je veux rajouter encore un mot il y
a peu un des siens euh parmi les très
très braves gens qui se laissent tromper
et qui qui suivent sa route
mais quelqu'un m'a dit qu'il s'était
vanté d'avoir non pas fait comme il
avait d'abord dit un calembour fâcheux
quand il avait parlé des fours
crématoires pour le nom de Durafour mais
le deux ou TR jours après il se serait
vanté auprès de tout son état maajur
d'avoir eu là un trait de génie leur
disant que c'était parfaitement calculé
car ça faisait parler de lui plus que ne
l'urait fait une campagne publicitaire
qui aurait coûter des sommes
considérables c'est pas idiot comme
raisonnement scandaleux n'est-ce pas
c'est vrai que c'était payant du point
de vue pour faire parler de lui c'était
dégueulasse mais c'était payant on va
donc arrêter de parler de lui si vous
voulez bien et puis je
voulais je voulais venir sur
l'humanitaire parce que en alors il dit
qu'on aurait dû prévoir oui sans blague
est-ce qu'il il prend il pense que nous
sommes l'état est-ce qu'il pense que
c'est de nous que dépend de veiller à ce
qu'il y ait un toit pour tous les
Français non enfin sans blague et
pourquoi il l'a pas fait si c'est un
citoyen individuel de le faire mais ta
gueule faisle mon père Monsieur de
Charette qui est le ministre du Logement
est venu ici dans cette pièce il est V
voir qu'est-ce qu'il vous a promis et
bien il est venu nous nous sommes
téléphonés depuis nous nous reverrons et
je me suis trouvé devant un homme de
bonne volonté compétent capable et je
pense qu'il y a besoin de du harcèlement
c'est le rôle des association militante
qui elle voit euh les mamans qui
pleurent euh n'est-ce pas sur le
trottoir bon alors que le ministre il
peut pas voir de la même manière il voit
des statistiques il voit des programmes
euh il faut que nous l'aidions à pleurer
de temps en temps n'est-ce pas et et je
crois qu'il est homme qui de cœur
capable de le vouloir mais mais euh là
il y a deux choses il y a plusieurs
pendant le peu de temps qui nous reste
mais qui pour moi beaucoup d'importance
euh une c'est une parenthèse
euh dans le journal hier on m'a tout de
suite téléphoné pour me dire le chagrin
que ça a provoqué chez mes compagnons
euh dans les communautés d'maus le
journal vendredi samedi dimanche en
première page avec d'ailleurs des
articles intéressants sur des personnes
qui font des actions de très haute
valeur
n'est-ce pas mais mettez un franc de sur
la vente de chaque numéro sera remis au
compagnons de la B pierre alors nous
sommes nous compagnons des Maus très
pointilleux sur un point c'est que nous
sommes probablement l'unique organisme
au monde qui ouvre une porte qui ne sait
pas qui va entrer et qui cherche comment
on va l'occuper qui refuse des subsides
de l'état et qui non seulement gagne son
pain mais veut travailler plus que son
suffisant pour se payer le luxe alors
qu'on se sentait des marginaux se payer
de trop se payer luxe des donateurs
l'année d'avant ils avaient donné près
de 3 milliards de centimes après avoir
nourri 4000 hommes et payer la sécurité
sociale et cetera alors on tient
beaucoup et ça je demande à la FP de
l'écouter et puis de le diffuser dans
tous les journaux n'est-ce pas que
chaque fois qu'on dit on veut donner de
l'argent à emus on dise pas aux
compagnons des Maus on dise on veut le
donner pour que ça s'ajoute à ce que
donnent les compagnons et là alors ils
seront contents parce qu'ils verront
qu'ils ont été provocateurs bien
Jean-Marie colomani euh longtemps
pendant plus plusieurs années l'action
humanitaire notamment à l'extérieur des
frontières a été au premier plan de
l'action gouvernementale notamment avec
Bernard Kouchner et depuis quelques
temps il y a une espèce d'inversion dans
la pensée sur ce sujet au point qu'on
voit certains
accuser l'humanitaire là où
l'humanitaire est intervenu d'avoir
presque prolongé la guerre comment
est-ce que vous réagissez à ce à ce
genre de chos il est évident que si on
laisse les les belligérants qu'il soient
attaquant ou victime crevit de faim la
guerre
finira c'est une des manières de finir
la guerre de tuer tout le monde n'est-ce
pas c'est c'est grotesque de prétendre
que parce que on empêche les gosses de
mourir
euh manquant de lait ou de minimum c'est
grottesque de dire que ça entretient la
guerre euh on on on apporte de l'aide
mais couchner tu m'as dit ça un jour euh
je sais que quand je suis en train de
soigner un gamin
euh quand il je vais lui dire tu peux y
aller tu tiens bien sur tes jambes il
n'aura qu'une â c'est d'aller chercher
le fusil d'un cadavre dans un coin de
rue pour redevenir combattant parce que
c'est presque un jeu à vos yeux ça ne ça
à vos yeux ça ça ne délégitime pas
l'humanitaire
l'humanitaire alors il y a il y a un
endroit en Europe où euh on considère
que l'humanitaire aurait dû céder le le
pas au militaire au contraire c'est la
Bosnie c'est la Yougoslavie l'ancienne
youoslavie comment jugez-vous la
situation est-ce que vous pensez que là
l'Europe a manqué un rendez-vous est-ce
que la France est-ce que la France a été
coupable si oui de quoi parce que la
France dans dans l'action humanétaire a
été le pays qui en a a fait le plus
soyons juste le l'Europe était trop
jeune elle n'était pas prête à une
action commune efficace dans la
deuxièmement deuxièmement les gens de
mon âge et je pense à miteran qui est
tout à fait la même génération nous
gardons le souvenir
épouvantable de la cruauté des nazis
Croates lorsque l'armée d'Hitler est
entrée en Croatie et que avec ané
pabelic les ustachis ont fait le
massacre des bohémiens des Juifs des des
Serbes des musulmans pour une grande
Croatie et nous gardions le souvenir les
Croates étaient les salot et et les
Serbes étaient les victimes et nous
restions dans cette idée sommaire en
réalité entre-temps les Croates
n'avaient plus les nazis derrière eux
pour les approvisionner et les Serbes
avant que tombe en poussière le régime
soviétique avait été abreuvé en armes de
toutes sortes si bien que les rôles
étaient renversés et on entendait si dès
qu'on a garde les Serbes tenir
exactement les propos que tenaient il y
a 40 ans les Croates purification
ethnique n'est-ce pas c'est pour ceux
qui ont
vécu le racisme hier ces mots c'est
c'est intolérable et et et pour moi je
ne peux avantti on nous a fait une
émission à la télévision très
intéressante pour n montrant comment on
pouvait observer avec les satellites ou
par avion exactement où étaient les
blocos du côté serbe
ou on fait des discours aux Nations
Unies mais mais si on termine pas la
motion voté à l'ONU en disant si demain
vous n'arrêtez pas on bombarde on
anéantit les batteries puison sait où
elles sont c'est pour moi
intolérablez j'ai est où nousmes chose à
faire que que que nous n'ayons pas fait
pour la Bosnie il faut que
l'Europe devienne adulte et que on la
prenne au sérieux quand elle a bien
étudié un problème et qu'elle agit je
voudrais avant que ce soit la
fin parler de deux
sujets qui touch l'islam et
Israël
j'ai des affections des amitiés
profondes des deux côtés
j'ai beaucoup souffert il y a un mois et
demi de l'assassinat d'un médecin
pédiaacre à Alger qui était notre
interlocuteur avec lequel on préparé une
fondation multiconfessionnelle à Alger
il a été assassiné et puis j'ai vu dans
la rue l'autre docteur
bien là où malgré toutes les bonnes
volontés on va se casser les dents ça va
être
Jérusalem à cause du statut de la ville
et une idée forte m'est venu mais c'est
peut-être une occasion de la rendre
publique et que elle germe dans des
cerveaux plus capables que le mien mais
est-ce que ça ne serait pas la solution
de créer un état de souverain de
Jérusalem comme il y a une cité comme il
y a eu le Liban dans lequel une une
charte verbale faisait que le Président
de la République serait toujours
maronite le président de l'Assemblée
nationale serait toujours sunite le
président du gouvernement euh plutôt du
gouvernement seraitunite de l'Assemblée
nationale serait chiite et il y aurait
toujours deux ministres des la minorité
de rus bon et ça a vécu comme ça 40 ans
dans la paix totale et c'était un
paradis ce Liban mais ça serait si beau
de faire que musulmans juifs et
chrétiens soi d'accord pour constituer
un État souverain le Luxembourg a autant
de poid que l'ONU quand il faut voter
dans un débat et bien pourquoi pas
Jérusalem un dernier mot pour les
Musulmans de Bosnie je crois que vous
aviez pensé à une opération pour la la
fin de l'année alors oui vous faites
bien de me le rappeler
euh il y a le la volonté que au moment
de Noël il soit dit partout dans les
écoles dans les les églises dans les
temples les synagogues les mosquées il
soit dit partout le 1er juillet le 1er
janvier 1er janvier allumer une bougie
sur le bord de votre fenêtre moi gosse
de Lyon c'était fait le 8 décembre les
bougies sur les fenêtres bien bien
allumer une bougie non pas pour la paix
c'est c'est trop vague pour la
tolérance pour se supporter les uns les
autres et si l'Europe réussissait ça à
faire ce geste qui n'a aucune portée
militaire aucune portée alimentaire mais
qui serait un signe pour nous apprendre
apprendre aux petits enfants que c'est
c'est de se tolérer quiit c'est qu'on
peut vivre entre frères et sœurs entre
enfants et parents et si on et voisins
et si on se tolère
pas la vi n' plus de sens monsieur Labé
le moment est venu malheureusement de
nous quitter hein euh c'était donc
l'heure de vérité de l'abé pierre
enregistré hier samedi à dans la maison
de retraite des compagnons des maïs à
estville en Normandie alors prochaine
invité George Marchet qui était déjà
député à l'époque où vous l'étiez et
qu'il est toujours un demi-siècle près
d'un demi-sècle plus tard et qui m'a
envoyé avec un mot très gentil son livre
démocratie je lui ai répondu qu'elle
demain d'avoir pasis un point
d'interrogation alors si vous voulez en
savoir plus parce que je me rends bien
compte que ceux qui nous regardent sont
restés quand même un peu sur leur fin je
vous recommande la lecture du livre de
l'abéis Pierre et de Bernard couchter
Dieu et les hommes je vous recommande
cette
cassette une journée avec la bépierre
tourné le 13 septembre dernier à
l'occasion de vos de vos 80 ans mon père
et puis alors également tous les
journaux des sansabris alors vous avez
ici le
réverbère vous avez macadam et vous avez
fin de monde fin de sièle fin de siècle
pardon fin de
siècle et sur lequel vous voyez il y a
un article sur vous Mon père voilà alors
je vais maintenant vous passer le livre
d'or pour que vous le
signez et euh je je dis bon dimanche
donc à tous ceux qui nous ont suivi en
directis dire un mot
encore il y a le GAT alors le problème
du Gat il il il il ne retient que sur un
point où trouver solvable les
consommateurs
oui les consommateurs ils surabondent à
travers le monde ceux qui qui veulent
bouffer ce que nos paysans jettent euh
n'est-ce pas mais le problème est de
trouver les les solollevables alors ils
sont pas solevables parce qu'il y a le
problème de la dette parce qu'il y a le
nous ne donnons pas des prix suffisants
aux produits qui viennent de chez eux
minéraux ou alimentaires et cetera et
cetera alors je voudrais bien qu'un jour
il y ait le tirmonde et le carmonde euh
ayant un petit tabouret au gâes pour
dire à ces messieurs il y a peut-être
des trucs merci mon père on signe on
[Musique]
signe